pftot tuesday edition an opportunity for
us to talk about things we didn't have
time to get to in a show that was
surprisingly jam-packed today because
chris it is the slow time after all i
had a question yesterday for a pft
mailbag that i did our good friend at
mike likes dirt one of my all-time
favorite twitter handles and for the
record i do like dirt could the removal
of tom brady instantly have made the afc
east one of the most exciting slash
competitive divisions in the national
football league my first thought was yes
but then once i started looking around i
don't know chris let me i've already
written my thoughts about it let me hear
what you have to say and then i'll i'll
tell you whether i agree with you does
brady's departure for the nfc south make
the afc east one of the most exciting
competitive divisions in the league top
to bottom
well no it does not i think it makes it
more fun because it's just more wide
open than we've ever had in the last 20
years in the afc i mean i think that's
really the bottom line plus there's some
young quarterbacks right and josh allen
sam darnold uh tula down in miami and
now jared stidham to where you just
wonder who's going to kind of can take
control of this division and kind of run
with it so i think that's what makes it
exciting plus you know there's teams
that are building that i think we're
excited for new england for one we're
all kind of and i don't want to say all
because you and i aren't you know but i
think the most of the the media and the
public is kind of counting new england
out like they're not going to be
relevant this year i don't believe that
and i think buffalo is going to make a
play to be one of the better teams in
the afc and it's a big year for adam
gates and the new york jets and sam
darnold company and they've done some
good things so no i'm not going to say
it's the most exciting
it's better than maybe it's been in
years past but not the most exciting and
the most exciting division of football
to me
will still go back to the title holder
from last year and that's the nfc west
the nfc west got better i mean i don't
know how we could say that but i mean
they did and i just look at that with
the quarterbacks and the coaches and
some of the talent on those rosters and
go it's going to be hard to dethrone
them as the best division in the in the
game this year
we've already spitballed about the
possibility that with three wild card
teams per conference now the nfc west
could have
all four teams make it to the postseason
especially since their schedule includes
if all 16 games are played per team the
four teams of the afc east the four
teams of the nfces two of the weakest
divisions right now in football relative
to the other divisions nothing against
those teams but somebody's got to be the
weakest division the nfc west could
fatten up outside of their own division
kind of go you know around 500 as they
do the the home and home series with the
three other teams each and and uh yeah
they could have two three and in theory
four teams in the playoffs uh and i have
a hard time ranking i i'd say the 49ers
are the best but after that i'm really
struggling i i guess it goes 49ers
seahawks cardinals rams
but man how can the rams were just in
the super bowl 15 months ago how in the
hell can we put them in fourth place in
their own division that tells you how i
don't know it is right now well yeah it
is it's that loaded but don't put them
at the fourth spot i i think they still
deserve the respect to be the third spot
in front of the the cardinals as excited
as i am about kyla murray and cliff
kingsbury and you're two and deandre
hopkins i'm with you
yep i mean i'm with you i'm very excited
but i'm not gonna like throw them in
front of the rams yet the rams quietly
had a good draft they've had a pretty
good off season
you know and then with sean mcvay and
company i mean you know they're gonna be
tough they're battle tested so i'm not
counting the rams out certainly not they
were in that playoff combo all year but
the real question is like who's what's
the second toughest division i think
that's really where the big the big
thing lies i mean who do you think of
mike mike i mean nfc south afc west
uh asc south i guess that's the ones i
look at i mean i know the afc north is
in that combo too there's a lot of good
divisions with some interesting story
lines of teams where
hey they got great quarterbacks or this
team's desperate and this coaching staff
better than win this year or they're
going to get fired whatever it may be
but i think i would probably give the
nfc south
second billing right now as we sit here
in may
well and i think that the real question
is which team in these various divisions
is the weakest link because that can
drag the division down it can't be three
teams that are competitive and one crap
team now in the afc north we don't know
how it's going to go this year it could
be all four teams are competitive it
could be joe burrow makes the bengals
relevant and contenders right away in
the afc south there's a perception that
jaguars are tanking or uh falling apart
inadvertently as they try to save jobs
of the head coach in the gm but they
could end up if these folks are right
and i'm not sure they are they can end
up dragging down the perception of the
rest of the division you know the same
thing in the south if the panthers i
mean we don't know what the panthers are
going to do with matt rule as the head
coach you're right bridgewater is the
quarterback but they kind of stand out
as the team that would maybe keep that
from being top to bottom a great
division you know the nfc north nfc
north i mean i you know last year i felt
like that division was wide open and any
of the teams could have won the division
and early on you know the lions were
much better than we thought they were
going to be the bears were showing some
promise i think this year i don't know
that you know a lot of these decisions
feel like there are two contenders and
two teams that really uh are gonna have
a hard time and in the afc east it's the
jets and the and the dolphins who have
to bridge the gap in the nfc east it's
washington and the giants who have to
bridge the gap and i think in the nfc
north it's the bears and the lions who
have to close that gap between them and
the packers and the vikings so i think
what we're saying then you know to me
just flushing this out i mean we're in
agreement that the nfc west is the best
division in football
but then to me it sounds like and i'm in
agreement with you here it's the nfc
south or the afc west which would be
second and you're right carolina is a
question mark you know in the nfc south
but brady and brees and matt and ryan
and the fact that hey the falcons and
dan quinn and thomas dimitrov they might
be on the hot seat if things don't go
well for them it's breeze and brady's
lat you know last year at least breezes
last year brady is last two so i look at
that but then you know to your point
with the nfc west mike or afc west
excuse me
i don't know if they have that team
that you know we look at to go oh
they're really poor you know i know the
chargers went 5-11 last year but they
were 12-4 the year before and like you
said many times even last year they
could have been ten and six i mean they
they had a lot of chances to pull out
some some games late in the you know
late late on uh in the game to win and
just didn't deliver so i think the more
i sit here i want to go
i'm going to give the nfc south the edge
just a little bit over the afc west
right now uh but i think it's more
because of the quarterback play i'm
giving it the advantage
you know it is weird though that these
divisions all have that who doesn't
belong and why team and the raiders
would stand out i think
yeah the chiefs chargers and broncos and
you know what this is going to be
this is going to be the ultimate test
for derrick carr because if the raiders
do end up clearly alone in the basement
this year
it's it it's done i'm surprised that
he's still the starting quarterback i
know his numbers aren't horrible but
you're not winning the kind of games
that john gruden is going to want to win
and if we see drew lock make great
strides this season if we see the
chargers with tyrod taylor or justin
herbert being competitive and the
raiders stand out as the fourth place
team their first year in las vegas i
think that could be it i it's got to be
it for derek carr if it goes that way
but if the raiders can can put something
together they could be top to bottom
every bit as dangerous as the nfc west
and you could have multiple playoff
teams come out of that division chris
well i you know i think your thoughts
right there though i mean you know again
derek carr
yeah it hasn't been like stellar it
hasn't been bad either this year though
will be a huge year for him and i think
you know they've improved some talent
around him to give him a chance to
succeed and and you know quiet the
doubters of him out there but you know i
i think you know to what you're saying a
little bit more about the afc west too
the more i think about it the more i
probably go yeah you're right the
raiders are that team that i question
you know the raiders are the one team in
the division that i look at that doesn't
really have an elite side of the ball to
talk up you know the chargers i can sit
here and go this is one of the best
defenses in football the broncos i can
sit here and go it's one of the best
defenses in football and watch out for
the offense we know about the chiefs and
it's one of the best offenses the most
explosive offenses we've ever seen in
the history of football the raiders
you know what is it we know they have a
really good offensive line uh but after
that you know i mean i don't know mike
i'm going to sit here and just do this
like what were they off that they were
the 25th offense in football last year
you know so you look at that or no i'm
wrong they're not the 25th offense in
football i'm totally wrong hold on i
messed up i'm on the wrong year where
were they offensively last year just let
me make sure i got this right so i don't
mess this up
uh i don't have it in front of me but
i'll look it up this is the this is
live
at least we're just live to tape please
yeah that's all right please ignore our
dust as chris sims checks his stats from
2019. they had josh jacobs who was a
rookie of the year candidate and a lot
of raiders fans upset that jacobs didn't
ultimately get that prize
the passing game was well that yeah that
and i think the better it would have
been if antonio brown hadn't flamed
right now they're relying on henry ruggs
to do a lot right out of the gates i
think it's a lot of pressure to put on
him but you know look
derek carr
isn't a horrible quarterback i just
don't think that
i i just don't think he's the guy for
john gruden maybe he hears someone else
i just don't think he's the guy for john
gruden chris and i think that if they
fade
into fourth place in the afc west this
year this is the year that gruden's
going to come to that conclusion yeah
well i would bet anything that if they
fought if they fade the fourth and the
west you know it's going to get blamed
on derek carr regardless unless he has
such a phenomenal statistical year that
gruden and the organization can't blame
him and then they'll then they'll have
to figure out some other way to place
blame on somebody or something else but
you know again i think derek carr is
more than a capable nfl starting
quarterback i do now do i question yes
his personality with john green
certainly i'm with you all the way there
but this will be a big year and you know
i stand corrected they were better
offensively last year than than i gave
them credit for in my mind and i had my
my my uh wrong wrong year up on my nfl
jesus there but uh this is gonna be a
big year for him the passing game
especially they built a special
offensive line you talked about jacobs
being special but you know all right so
come down to it though who are we saying
the afc west is the second best division
in the game other than you know uh being
behind the nfc west
first of all for anyone who wonders what
nfl jesus is that's a industry reference
to a website that has comprehensive
statistical information for media
members and it's nfl
gsis those are the initials for whatever
it ultimately stands for people call it
game staff information site
all right but that's not as easy to say
as nfl jesus jsis anyway i'm looking at
the afc west now and it is amazing only
one of the teams was above 500 last year
only one of the teams was at or above
500. broncos 79 raiders 79 charges 5 and
11 and you mentioned the raiders were
11th in offense they only scored 313
points they were third place in their
own division in scoring and they had a
minus 106
minus 106 scoring differential so when
they when they lost they got blown off
the field i mean the those are
embarrassing numbers anytime you're
triple digits in point differential that
is not good
um i i i'm going to go with the nfc west
as the strongest and i'm going to go
with the afc west based upon projected
improvements this year i think they'll
be number two
okay i like that i'm gonna make the afc
west number three for me i'm gonna give
the nfc south number two right now even
though i know carolina's a little bit of
a question i do like what matt and rule
and company are doing there but i i
guess i just like the the top three a
lot and the falcons we know have a lot
of talent on their roster it's a big
year
matt ryan's kind of you know he's still
a really really good quarterback that i
think people have forgotten i just got
to think there's certain motivations
within that organization that get them
back into the playoff combo and make
them relevant in the nfl and just you
know again i think the bucks and saints
uh are going to be towards the top of
that conversation in the nfc so that's a
good talk good talk
but a very real scheduling dynamic if
we're going to compare the nfc west and
the nfc south again the west plays the
four teams of the nfc east and the afc
east each
the nfc south plays all four teams from
the nfc north and all four teams from
the afc west so it's a tougher out of
division slate
for those teams than for the nfc west so
i think collectively the nfc west is
going to seem better just because half
of that's half of your schedule those
eight games are half of your schedule
those two other divisions where you play
every team in them and as we as we
segregate these these divisions you do
get a benefit if you play a weaker
division and it's a detriment if you end
up playing obviously a stronger division
all right let's call it there pftot done
for tuesday we'll be back again on
wednesday chris sims unbutton coming up
later today chris and paul burmeister
are going to redraft the 2016 draft
check that out wherever you get your
podcast
and we'll see oh and i'm going to talk
to tom curran later today from nbc
sports boston on the pftpm podcast we
tentatively have that set up i want to
get his thoughts on this josh mcdaniels
tom brady story plus other things
relating to the aftermath of the tom
brady departure from new england so
check that out as well we'll see
everybody back here on wednesday
see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports